Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
C’est l’histoire d’un homme de l’ombre
qui n’a jamais cherché la lumière,
mais que les événements ont conduit
sous les feux de l’actualité
et les feux des projecteurs.
Nombreux sont les pas de côté qui ont
modifié le cours de mon existence.
Élevé dans une famille catholique,
croyante et pratiquante,
j’étais un bon chrétien.
Mais, dès l’âge de douze ans,
j’ai constaté que les voies du Seigneur
étaient vraiment impénétrables
et j’ai pris un chemin de traverse qui
m’a amené tout droit à la mécréance.
Et c’est ainsi qu’au grand désespoir
de mes parents, je suis devenu athée.
Plus qu’un pas de côté,
c’était véritablement un grand écart.
À 17 ans, j’intègre l’école militaire
préparatoire d’Aix-en-Provence.
Avec 99% de réussite au baccalauréat,
on nous promet un bel avenir,
comme l’indique d’ailleurs
la devise de l’école :
« Cadets d’aujourd’hui,
colonels de l’an 2000. »
J’y pratique assidûment le parachutisme
et la plongée sous-marine.
C’est à cette occasion
que je découvre une spécialité
qui m’attire et qui m’intrigue
en même temps.
On me dit que c’est secret
et que c’est très difficile,
que c’est très dangereux
et peu indiqué pour faire carrière.
C’est justement
ce qui va renforcer ma détermination
à devenir un jour nageur de combat.
J’intègre par la suite
l’École Spéciale Militaire de Saint-Cyr
pour une période de deux années
à l’issue de laquelle le choix
de l’arme va être déterminant
pour la carrière d’un officier.
L’arme qui a la cote,
c’est la gendarmerie.
Elle offre dix places
aux 200 Saint-Cyriens sortant d’école.
Je suis 17e de ma promotion
et je peux choisir cette fameuse 10e
et dernière place tant convoitée,
parce que c’est celle-là
qui mène à la voie royale
et plus tard à la piste aux étoiles -
celles de général.
Mais moi, je m’accroche à mes rêves,
je veux être nageur de combat
et la gendarmerie n’est pas
la meilleure voie pour y parvenir.
Et c’est ainsi que je fais ce pas de côté
qui sidère mes camarades
et mes instructeurs
en choisissant les troupes de Marine.
Et puis l'année suivante,
les parachutistes.
Mais il me faudra attendre
encore trois ans
avant de pouvoir me présenter à l’école de
plongée de Saint-Mandrier près de Toulon,
pour faire ce fameux cours nageur.
Ce sont six mois d’épreuves
extrêmement sélectives,
heureusement couronnées de succès,
qui me permettent de rejoindre le Centre
d’instruction des nageurs de combat
à Aspretto, en Corse,
et qui est un des fleurons
du service Action du SDECE,
les services secrets de l'époque,
ancêtre de la DGSE actuelle.
Mais pour moi,
ce n’est pas un aboutissement,
ce n’est que le début
d’une grande aventure.
L’entraînement y est intensif,
doublé d’une formation clandestine.
Deux ans après mon arrivée,
je suis au top de ma forme,
mais malheureusement,
je suis victime d’un accident de
décompression lors d’une plongée profonde.
Cloué sur mon lit à l’hôpital
de la Marine à Toulon,
je suis paralysé
des deux jambes et d’un bras.
On me remonte le moral, on m’assure
qu’on ne me laissera jamais tomber
et que même en fauteuil roulant,
on me trouvera un poste administratif
quelque part à Paris.
Moi, je ne peux me résigner
à une telle fatalité.
Et je refuse de faire ce pas de côté que
mes proches voudraient bien que je fasse.
Et je m’accroche.
La nature est bien faite.
Je suis jeune,
nos médecins militaires font des miracles
et me remettent petit à petit sur pied.
Mais c'est à moi aussi
de prendre le relais.
Je suis persuadé
que la fonction crée l’organe,
donc je m’entraîne des heures
et des heures en salle de rééducation.
Tant et si bien que deux mois plus tard,
je peux rejoindre mon unité en Corse.
Alors bien sûr, la marche
m'est encore pénible.
J’ai l’impression d’avoir un sac
de dix kilos sur le dos en permanence,
mais dans l’air et dans l’eau,
en apesanteur, je me sens bien.
Et c’est dans l’eau et sous l’eau
que je vais me reconstruire.
Trois ans après mon accident,
j’ai récupéré 80%
de mes capacités physiques.
Je vais participer
à une opération dans le Pacifique.
Il s’agit de neutraliser un bateau
d’une organisation écologiste
qui s’apprête à appareiller
du port d’Auckland
pour s’opposer aux essais
nucléaires français à Mururoa.
La mort accidentelle
d’un membre d’équipage
et l’arrestation de deux de nos agents
chargés des repérages et de la logistique
vont déclencher un des plus grands
scandales de la Cinquième république.
À Paris, c’est la curée.
Les journalistes veulent
le Watergate à la française.
Le président, le Premier ministre
et son gouvernement sont sur la sellette.
Mon équipier et moi,
qui avons accompli la partie
sous-marine de cette opération,
nous sommes rentrés à notre base.
Nous sommes passés entre les mailles du
filet tendu par la police néo-zélandaise.
Et pas vu, pas pris, nous n’existons pas.
Du moins, c'est ce qu'on pensait.
Parce que deux mois plus tard,
nos grades et nos véritables identités
sont dévoilés dans la presse,
entraînant de ce fait la démission
du ministre de la Défense
et le limogeage
du chef des services secrets.
Ce sont les derniers fusibles
qu’on fait sauter
pour préserver le Président
et le Premier ministre.
Inutile de chercher
à qui profite la trahison.
Et moi, trahi par mes propres gouvernants,
je m’apprête à poser ma démission,
mais je suis directeur de l’instruction
et je ne peux me résoudre à abandonner
mes hommes dans la tourmente.
Et c’est ainsi que je continue
encore quelques années les opérations
qui, du fait des longues absences
qu’elles incluent,
vont gravement impacter ma vie familiale.
Je suis marié, j’ai deux enfants et
mon couple bat sérieusement de l’aile.
Alors on propose
de me trouver un poste tranquille
pendant deux ans
pour préparer l’École de guerre
qui dure aussi deux ans.
Mais,
le fait de rester quatre ans dans
les bureaux ne m’enchante guère.
Par ailleurs, le service a besoin
d’un officier supérieur
pour mettre sur pied et encadrer la garde
présidentielle du président guinéen
qui fait appel à l'aide de la France.
C'est un poste en famille,
alors j'accepte.
Ce pas de côté que je vais faire
va définitivement m’écarter
de la voie royale qui m’était offerte.
Mais je préférais de loin
l’aventure sur les pistes africaines.
Trois ans plus tard, mission accomplie.
Récompense suprême, on me confie le
commandement des nageurs de combat.
Ce seront trois années riches
sur le plan humain et professionnel,
à la tête d’hommes exceptionnels,
mais malheureusement entachées
par la mort de quatre de mes hommes
qui périssent en mer
au cours d’un exercice de nuit.
Un peu plus tard,
refusant alors un poste
à l’état-major du service Action,
je fais encore un nouveau pas de côté
pour échapper à la sédentarité
et me voilà parti pour de nouvelles
aventures aux Comores.
À peine arrivé, j’y serai amené
à négocier de la libération du Président
et la reddition
des mercenaires de Bob Denard
lors de son dernier coup d’État de 1995.
De retour en France,
félicité par le directeur général,
je suis nommé
à la Direction des opérations.
Mais là, j’y apparais désormais
comme le dernier dinosaure,
rescapé du fiasco de 1985.
Trop loin du terrain,
trop près des politiques,
je ne me sens absolument pas
à l’aise à cet endroit.
C’est alors que je vais faire
ce pas de côté
que j’ai hésité à faire
dix ans auparavant,
en quittant un service à qui j’aurais
consacré 17 années de mon existence.
L’aventure continue
quand même encore en Afrique,
dans le cadre de la coopération militaire
et de la Direction
du renseignement militaire.
Mais fuyant encore une fois
la grisaille parisienne,
je me porte volontaire pour être détaché
auprès des Nations Unies
pour une mission de maintien de la paix
en République démocratique du Congo.
Je suis détaché comme
officier de liaison au Burundi.
C’est un petit pays en proie
à la guerre civile.
On assassine aussi bien
le nonce apostolique,
le représentant de l’UNICEF
et d’autres membres des Nations Unies.
On me propose d’assurer
la sécurité des agences sur place.
Je contacte ma direction
du personnel à Paris
qui me conseille de saisir
cette opportunité
car n’étant pas breveté de l’École
de guerre, je ne serai jamais général.
C’est ainsi que, au grade de colonel,
je fais mon adieu aux armes
après 27 ans de bons et loyaux services.
Ce pas de côté que j’ai fait
pour basculer dans la vie civile
s’imposait de lui-même,
et je l’ai franchi allègrement.
Durant 15 années encore,
les Nations Unies vont me déployer
dans toutes les zones de conflit
d’Afrique et du Moyen-Orient.
Mais c’est une histoire qu’il me serait
impossible de résumer en quelques minutes.
Aussi pour finir,
je dirai qu’en dépit des remords
qui m’assaillent encore,
car le nombre de vies que j’ai pu sauver
ne pourra jamais compenser
celles que je n’ai pu préserver.
Mais pour tout le reste, je dirais
que, non, je ne regrette rien.
Alors pour vous :
vivez vos rêves jusqu’au bout
et vivez pleinement votre vie.